[Music]
so what we're here today to talk to you
about is how we're working to transform
Dow Jones into a data business so the
data engineering team which Dylan was
manager of we had the opportunity to
move a 30 an over a 30 year archive the
premium news data to the cloud and by
experimentation with cloud-based
services we're able to identify usage
patterns and optimize our architecture
in order to meet those usage patterns so
what we're going to talk to you today is
how we were able to learn through
experimentation how we're able to
identify opportunities to either
optimized for cost or optimize for
customer performance and how those
lessons learned have influenced how
we're transforming our business and
future proofing in future data driven
developments ok Dow Jones had an over a
30 year archive of premium news data
that existed only an on-premise of
infrastructure what we discovered is
that it met the need of our existing use
cases which were predominantly around
advanced research and advanced analytics
predominately focused at research
librarians while we were getting
increasingly frequent requests for
extractions of data and that was
actually really challenging in our
on-premise infrastructure so what the
data engineering team was charged with
doing was actually doing the migration
to the cloud to support existing use
cases for the Advanced Research new use
cases for machine learning and big data
workflows as well as being innovative
enough to be future proofing for
whatever is next so Dylan what were some
of the original challenges in making
this data available to customers so for
this new class of customers these data
scientists they required more data so we
were trying to like feel fulfill their
requests but they needed more data than
we needed for the researchers
so with this on-prem database we'd have
to give them the data on weekends or
over the the low traffic times that we
had for our research product but that
just wasn't working we weren't able to
fulfill the requests
summers that were needing this data as a
result we were actually post a question
are we going to stay on Prem and try to
scale up or we're going to move to the
cloud where we can massively scale up he
firmly like with the formal clouds so
due to this lack of bandwidth in this
lack of scale and the smaller the size
of our team we decided to move to the
cloud
specifically the Google cloud because
they gave us zero ops options I have
some listed here like data flow data
proc and also GCS I'll get over I'll go
over those when you go over the
architecture later so yeah I'm just
gonna hit home again what the pros and
cons are for moving to the cloud you can
scale massively especially for these
data science workloads where you're
going to need large clusters to process
all this data for us it's over 30 years
of news content from over 33,000 new
sources it also allows for smaller teams
because you have these managed services
that you can take advantage of it also
allows to give you disaster recovery
capabilities that previously were not
available because on Prem we only had a
limited number of locations with GCP or
with cloud offerings that we have
available to us now we can be located in
different countries throughout the world
and given this upfront costs we still
wanted to move forward to the cloud
I saw bring it over to Patricia to
continue us on our journey
well after I step us through the
architecture here so here's our
simplified architecture what we had was
a news content feed on the the right
side there it's kind of shown as a Mario
warp pipe and that fed into GCP our GCS
for storage and every day we'd have a
dataflow job that would process all that
those news events there were updates
deletes or additions of articles and
that be pushed into to datastore from
there our customers are interactive
Ian's API but this API we had we had to
apply custom dsls so that was
problematic Allah
with the fact that it was pretty
expensive off the cuff here in all that
Patricia
let's continue on so once the 30-year
archive was moved to the cloud what we
wanted to enable was really this the
opportunity to integrate our data with
machine learning workflows as well as
big data workflows so we discovered that
we identified two delivery mechanisms
that we wanted to enable via cloud
services first delivery mechanism was
what's called a snapshot and that's a
downloadable extraction of data custom
data set for whatever is the specific
use case that can be either transferred
to a to a cloud provider to work in
existing workflows or can be downloaded
to their to any enterprise customers
on-premise behind a firewall so if it's
F privacy is an issue we're able to meet
that need the second delivery mechanism
we enabled was what's called a stream
and that's a custom filter of incoming
news of near real-time ingestion that
can either be used to keep a data store
up-to-date or it can be used for things
like risk target identification brand
management at scale due diligence at
scale these are the delivery mechanisms
we wanted to investigate in and make
available by the DNA platform what we
discovered early on in our initial
experimentation with cloud architecture
is that the usage pattern moving to the
cloud gives us a better opportunity to
track and identify and understand our
usage patterns and our architecture
needs to be adjusted to meet the needs
of our usage patterns and we identified
kind of trade-off decisions that were
either to optimize cost or to optimize
the performance for our customer one
opportunity so what we're going to do
today is we're going to use this balance
as an analogy for what is either the the
optimization of costs that's enabled by
a cloud services or the opportunity to
improve your performance to your
customers by cloud by leveraging cloud
services cost optimizations if we were
going to improve our cost for example in
the use case of a snapshot which is a
downloadable extraction what we
identified as the usage pattern is very
consistent so these are workloads that
can be done in batch processing these
are workloads that can whisk
interruption so what we have is we could
make an investment in cost optimization
by doing by using preemptable instances
we could invest in cost optimization by
investing in tiered storage by
leveraging the advantages of tier
storage you could do this the same with
sustained use discounts and you'll
notice as we leverage the cost
optimization the performance may go up
and it excusing the performance may
degra gate so you're as you're as you're
optimizing either for cost or
performance the key is not necessary
finding equilibrium it's finding
striking the right balance of cost to
performance for that specific use case
now streams on the other hand which is a
near real-time filter of data well that
we would really heavily weight being
highly available and being reliable in
that event we'd really want to invest in
managed services and we'd want to invest
in readwrite access I and we'd also want
to invest in analytics capabilities so
in investing in our performance the
performance time goes down but the costs
may go up so it's really as I mentioned
never a man a matter of trying to strike
equilibrium it's a matter of trying to
find the balance that meets your
specific use case so Dylan once the data
was made available on the cloud can you
walk us through some of the costs to
performance trade-offs that you
discovered with datastore yeah so with
datastore we were giving high
bioavailability of reads and writes and
also it integrates really well with our
pipelining tool data flow it also allows
us to scale a lot better than we did on
Prem some of the cons where it's very
expensive for the read and write
operations six for the especially for
the usage patterns we were seeing on top
of that we had to create our own DSL and
educate our customers on that DSL so
there was a better way for us to move
forward in patrícia yeah so for the
product of snapshots
we do require analytics capabilities but
we also require the readwrite
capabilities datastore proved to be a
little bit to really have meet the need
for analytics for the performance
expectation of our customers but did not
meet the
cost performant needs so so Dylan what
were some of the advantages in moving
towards bigquery as our search index
yeah so I'll explain the architecture
and then kind of bring to light the the
optimizations we made that made this a
better architecture than the one that we
had for for datastore and I'm gonna
explain it from from right to left
starting with the Mario pipeline of
content and so yeah that's still feeding
in into GCS with those events that were
using to update our archive and then we
still have that dataflow pipeline that
updates daily except the difference here
is we separated our core you layer from
our storage layer and we for a query
layer we use bigquery and big Cray
allows us to have that sequel the
standard siegel syntax that we can use
and allow our customers to leverage as
well and also we have GCS to store our
full set of content
another reason we had to split our query
layer and our storage layer was because
there were some limitations with
bigquery specifically the extraction
limits that we ran into we do not run
into this with the current architecture
and I'll kind of bring that to light
through the customers journey when they
submit a request for a snapshot and that
can be seen here on the right side our
customers interact with the api's and
what they're requesting is a snapshot of
data and once they submit that request
an example request to be for all English
English content that we have in our
archive and that'll kick off a data flow
snapshot or a data flow job and what
that data flow table will do is it'll go
to bigquery with that where clause and
grab all the the IDS of the articles the
most the identifiers for the most
current version of each article and from
that point it'll do a CO group co group
by key or I just sort of join with the
the data we have stored on GCS from that
point once it has all the the content
identified it'll then output the
snapshot to a location that the customer
can use to to download it but that's
still done via our API is and our
customer still has no idea that we're no
longer using data store so that's the
architecture and I'll kind of reiterate
the the pros and cons of this
so with these resources that we're
spending up with data flow the affirm
their referrals so we're not incurring
that cost as time goes on we're only
incurring the cost while we're doing the
operation we're doing the snapshot for
example we're not paying a high price
for updates to the archive as we were
before with data flow sorry datastore
often we get that free query syntax that
bigquery gives us with with sequel and
GCS is very cheap so it's the perfect
place to store our data when we're not
using it so with this architecture we
still have that very expensive joining
process with the Lecrae layer and the
storage layer and we also need a
separate cluster for each in every
operation so there may be a better way
and you may see that further on in our
talk here in moving to using bigquery
for analytics we were able to do big
workflows and relatively inexpensive big
queries relatively inexpensive for
analytics capabilities but we hit some
quotas and we had some limits when it
came to extraction which is why we then
paired with Google cloud stores we
really use the the cost optimizations of
the tiered storage with the analytics
capabilities of bigquery so Dylan in our
snapshots architecture why was the mood
made from data flow to data proc okay
yeah I'll explain this architecture and
you may see the cons kind of bubble up
or what what no longer are cons with
this are this architecture so here we
still have that that Mario pipeline of
content going into GCS updating daily
and going into the content archive we
have here that's a little different as
you may see the customers still
submitting API requests but when the
customer submits an API request for all
English content this time they're just
going to be having a job spin up and we
can use data proc and their sequel
syntax to create the snapshot of content
that'll be delivered to our customer
there was there were some cons with this
method but yeah I'll go over those after
I go over the pros because this is a
good thing
so with this architecture we were able
to reach share resources so when we had
to customers make a snapshot request we
can still use that same archive of
content with data flow you'd have to
load it into our cluster each time each
and every time here we can reuse the
same we can mount the same drive in the
same content so this also more closely
aligns with our usage patterns we have
more and more customers join and use our
platform and because of that we can use
these higher cost resources when it
comes to doing the operations there's
also no need for that joining of the
query layer and the storage layer
because we're using spark on data proc
which has a sequel syntax that we can
leverage but with this there is still
more operational overhead with with data
flow it can recover from errors or any
issue with the cluster with data proc we
still have to kind of build in some
logic to kind of restart the cluster and
recover from errors on top of that when
we moved from bigquery and went to the
spark syntax we had to create some UDF's
to kind of get bridge that gap between
functionality and yeah for those of you
interested it was it was related to
regular expressions and I'll throw it
over to Patricia to continuous on this
journey so we have a relatively small
team we started with two engineers and
we now have five engineers through the
experimentation in moving to the cloud
we were able to identify that the usage
pattern for snapshots is very consistent
and it's very predictable so it was a
worthwhile trade-off to go to the
increased overhead of an unmanaged
service as it gave us a increasing
control over the expensive operations
like joining and windowing so there was
a cost benefit to us it was worth it and
worth taking on the the overhead so
Dylan what were some of it for streams
which is a near real-time filtered
stream of data where highly available
services is weighted heavier what was
the what was the choice made to move
from data flow to data proc or did a
prokta data flow okay yeah with with the
streams architecture our customers are
going to notice if it goes down for a
few minutes or seconds
unlike with snapshots they're not going
to notice because it's those operations
are going to take between an hour or two
hours this it's very its low latency so
they're gonna notice when messages are
not streaming to them with this we're
still hooking into that stream of
content that's coming from the Marne
YouTube but it's streaming on to pub/sub
right now and we're still leveraging the
data flow services to do our ETL
processes and the great thing about
dataflow is you can write job for a
batch or streaming job and it's going to
be either the same or similar so we're
taking an advantage of some of the code
we wrote for snapshots and usually in
streams to de filter and update our
content from that point we stream it out
to different we filter it into different
product types because we have content
that's that's licensed to only certain
products and we use data flow to filter
that content from there this is where
our customers kind of interact with our
system they use our user api's as if
they would be using a snapshot they
submit the same query like if they want
all English content they'll submit that
little where clause and from that point
we'll spin up a data flow filter before
though that was a data proc filter and
I'll go into the pros and cons as to why
we changed that part of the architecture
so now once the customer has created the
stream and they have their custom set of
content streaming to them on this
pub/sub topic here they can then use our
client code and get streamed all the
content that gets filtered down to them
but we had to make that move that I was
talking earlier from data proc to data
flow and that was because every time we
would use preemptable x' in our cluster
it would take down our our stream and
your customers would notice with what
data flow we actually have had streams
that have running for multiple years
along with that allows for this fully
managed zero ops data processing and for
our small team this is great because we
have to wake up in the middle of the
night and handle an issue it also allows
for more seamless auto scaling
which helps with smaller teams and with
streams there was not a heavy load as we
only receive like 800,000 messages a day
and in big data land that's not a lot so
yeah there were the cons of not being
able to use preemptable which were very
cheap if you do use data proc I I
suggest looking into it and also we had
to kind of leverage in in memory
database for the queries right we didn't
have the big query syntax or the the
spark syntax that we could plug into and
use sequel but if I were to do this
again
data flow now has a sequel to yourself
which we have not used Thor whatever to
you Patricia Thanks so sort of to
summarize some of the lessons learned
the usage patterns seem obvious but
actually once we release it to the world
we did have some api's that were used
from ways we hadn't intended and all of
a sudden your your costs go to skyrocket
and you start becoming very painfully
aware of where you have opportunity to
optimize where you have opportunity to
change and so what I would recommend and
advise is initially we were sort of
always optimizing for performant
responses and if you invest too heavily
in one side of the trade-offs you fall
over on top of your suit yourself if
you're only investing in one side you
get skewed off balance really quickly
and that becomes very apparent when you
get the bill for the service we had a
use case that have been like a $70,000
use case that we were not expecting so
what we really learned is in anytime we
do a feature development to first
identify the usage pattern identify the
behavior really understand from your
users how they're intending to use it
which might be different than your
original assumption and then once you do
understand the usage pattern to build in
such a flexible way that you can
understand the trade-off decisions
you're made versus the performant
experience for your customer and your
opportunities that the cloud enables you
to for cost optimizations so Dylan what
were some of the lessons you learned in
making this new product available on
Google Cloud ok yeah one thing that we
found useful as we're developing this
new product that we've not built before
was we built time in our road
to iterate and it spiked on new
infrastructure when we could Google is
always developing new like zero ops
tools that you can use and other cloud
providers are as well
we actually started on a different cloud
provider before we moved to Google also
we learned that being an early adopter
is a double-edged sword you can guide
the roadmap for their products but at
the same time you can use one of their
products and it can tip over in a way he
would not previously have expected also
Google very tightly they keep their
quotas down to a limit that prevent you
from incurring a lot of cost but at the
same time it could cause an issue in the
future so it's good to know your quotas
especially when you're an early adopter
so yeah
this can actually be boiled down to
three things when you're deciding in
architecture the first one is cost the
larger you can make that margin for cost
of operations the quicker you can grow
your team iterate on feed features
another one is team size there are there
are some architectures that may not work
for your small teams especially if you
want I have a team that can develop
features and you don't want to be
spending half at a time managing
infrastructure this is why Google
dataflow and in data proc have actually
come in handy for us and kind of
accelerated or roadmap another one is we
kind of learned trial by fire is usage
patterns we had a new product with a new
use case and our customers are reusing
in a way we did not expect them to use
it as a result we took advantage of the
fact that we had time and a roadmap from
using these zero operational tools and
also the fact that we built into a
roadmap this time for iterate iterating
our architecture so yeah luckily were
able to adapt and and change according
to this users patterns but it's very
important to keep a very tight eye on
that and maybe even log that data
somewhere so you can be alerted of when
like your costs are kind of spiking and
it's time to address that issue so those
are the lessons I learned so in making
this new product available on the cloud
we meet our existing use cases of
advanced research we've all
so now made a new line of business for a
machine learning and Big Data workflows
and dildos can walk us through some of
what we've also enabled in terms of
applying these lessons to even future
proofing and some kind of new and
upcoming things we've got going on yeah
so this was just about news content but
with news content you have different
entities you have organizations you have
people you have events you have like
different industries affecting the news
so there's a lot of context that can be
gleaned from different sets of data and
DNA has allowed us to kind of you like
build on the top of the shoulders of
this platform and creating products that
can generate knowledge and actually you
can get signal from these news events
and we're doing that by structuring a
sort of knowledge graph in the way that
Google is doing for their search engine
we're gonna be doing for the news and
events so we've been able to work on
that develop new context traversal
relations through like our graph
architecture and on top of that if
you're interested in the kind of content
we've been dealing with here we have a
commercial data set in bigquery just
Google bigquery commercial data sets DNA
and you can take a look at the kind of
news content we've been dealing with so
yeah that's the knowledge graph is kind
of the next big thing we've got coming
up and we're so excited to have this
premium news content but also available
with you know the entities that exist
the relationships between those entities
see if the data in the context of the
data which is something we're really
excited about
[Music]